hey what's up pretty babies
i'm geo and i'm bart and this is an
episode of get close
so let's do it and today we got a really
special episode it's a q a episode
because i feel like a lot of you guys
always want to talk to us um but we
don't really get that opportunity so i
posted on my instagram story i talked to
them all the time well maybe it's just
me then it's just you thank you and so
they asked a bunch of questions and i
picked a bunch of them
and hopefully we can get through all of
them
or some of them and we'll see
you ready i might just do a random
random one okay okay
oh no
damn it's getting down yeah real quick
okay brutus and rangers
asks
how do you guys make time for intimacy
seems like you guys are always so busy
we definitely are
pretty busy folks but what has helped
from my perspective is uh we have a
schedule for things so we wake up and
lucky for us right now we have our our
our gym in our garage
so we're able to train together so even
though like i'm training that's like a
really cool intimate moment that i get
to spend with you because i oh you don't
need to talk about [ __ ]
oh
is that what they're talking about
i mean what does intimacy mean doesn't
that just isn't that a fancy word for
doggy style i think
maybe
uh
[ __ ] then how do we find time well at
night that's when the [ __ ] or we
never do it at night i know we're so
tired
yeah no but yeah let's go let's go with
what you're talking about so what are
you talking about all right then you son
of a [ __ ] why do you cut me off derail
the whole thing this is really intimate
right now yeah and then you're like
you're talking about [ __ ] so i'm like
okay let's talk about [ __ ] things
you're like well there's no talk about
[ __ ] we're talking about emotional
intimacy
i i just think so the way i took the
question is just how do you find time to
spend
quality time
together okay you do yours i'll do
mineco that's what i was trying to do
dude this is quality time right now it's
not um
so what i was saying was so like when i
get a train with you i actually enjoy it
because like i i've never been the type
of girl that likes to just
veg out in a relationship like i like
doing it occasionally like what's
vegging out like watching tv on the
couch yeah like not doing [ __ ]
like just sitting around you know and
like lounging all the time
like i remember seeing my
family members and when they had
relationships it was like that it was
like the same thing like
come over and sit on the couch and just
watch movies and eat and like sit on the
couch again and like not much would
happen you know and and i'm pretty sure
a lot of that was because our parents
and our aunties and uncles were like
really strict so i'm sure that's where
that comes from but i think just viewing
it that way i'm like oh that's just so
boring so once in a while i do like to
veg out and sit on the couch and watch
movies or whatever but they might just
want to maybe maybe they just want to
hang but all the time i can't do it
that's not my style and i'm not saying
that there's anything wrong with that
style yeah if that's what if that's what
brings you pleasure dude by all means do
you but for me that's never been my
style i see so like um i like doing
things and by doing things i don't
necessarily mean like go shopping or
like go to amusement parks or whatever i
like experiences i consider it an
experience yeah and those are like like
not all the [ __ ] time either because
that could be very stressful but i just
like
either like a hobby or like training for
me is a hobby now like it's fun so like
like i get to make myself better and i
get to do that with my partner like
that's [ __ ] rad you know like i like
that we get to share these things and um
that for me is like an intimate time
that i get to spend with you because
like we get to see each other in a
different light like just [ __ ] going
balls to the walls and like hating [ __ ]
or failing or being down or or angry or
whatever right so like i get to
experience you in such a in such a like
controlled bubble i like that um
and then we have like our lunch break
together so we don't necessarily work in
on the same things like yes we work in
the same company but we're like
separate departments way different
departments um that when we do get to
sit together it's like co-workers like
at a lunch like in the lunch room yeah
and like
we're together we're not like on our
phones we're not working if anything
we're probably venting about work or we
just probably try not to talk about work
at all and we just try to connect these
people that to me is also intimate time
and then at night when we finally get to
put the monkey man to bed
you and i like will spend time together
um and like uh like that that those
those those little blocks of time are
pretty sacred to us
well to me at least that like i i just
like being next to you and like
sharing you know my little world with
you and then hearing you about your
world
yeah i agree i think with the intimacy
the emotional intimacy that's i feel the
exact same way but going back to the
doggy style question yes it did happen
on a tuesday
um and i think it did happen
on a wednesday as well
[Laughter]
so yeah i think for us um
uh having sex at night is
that's very difficult because once you
run businesses together and have a
toddler and have a toddler and then now
my dad lives with us so now there's an
additional person working another
toddler yeah there's like a lot of stuff
you know so by the time we get to our
bed at the end of the night we're
exhausted and we're trying to train our
ass off so just
everything
every ounce of additional
energy or calorie that we have is used
up so the times where we try to plan sex
at night doesn't happen but what we do
realize is midday um both me and geo's
hormones
are working real good
so if that's synced up
then hey it could happen you know on a
tuesday
and a wednesday
so um and you know what i think also
helps with that what actually the fact
that we're not eating like [ __ ]
[ __ ] really because we've been on a
shitty diet yeah well you more so you
think it [ __ ] up your i 100 think it
really [ __ ] with your hormones because
as soon as i started cleaning up my diet
again
um i'm going like oh i'm feeling a
little bit saucy
i really do think you think it's that i
eat like a [ __ ] [ __ ] when i let go
[ __ ]
do you think you think that's the diet
or the training
the hard concerns oh maybe the training
too because like our training before at
least my training before was a very
powerlifting focus which is very
heavy but like once in a while and then
you go back to like slow
reps yeah but this one's like a lot of
movement yeah yeah maybe that's like
also like doing a little boosty boost
and i think i'm we're also getting we're
trying to get shredded
so like we're also looking good so we're
feeling more confident yes a lot yeah
there's uh definitely like the hormonal
physiological and spiritual
cool um that was a funny question from
aloha yours
where's your next forever home
i actually really like vegas and
is this so funny that it's a joke now
and yeah we've called it a forever home
but at this rate i don't think we
consider anything forever because just
the way the world appears to be right
now is pretty [ __ ]
dysfunctional and like volatile
so for me i'm like nothing is forever
what's awesome is um i love it
when our viewers are also in on the joke
where we're like is this your forever
home yeah like the [ __ ] schneiders
and like they talk about that like ooh
that bag of schneider's looking really
sexy and i'm like god damn it bar why'd
you have to make that goddamn joke yeah
so i think for us um
i think it's what's really interesting
is we're at the cusp of really big
change right now and when i say us i'm
talking about like our generation
because like the whole forever home
concept
it's that is our intention you know
that's what we want because that's what
we know from the past right so like the
people that are maybe even like your
older sister's generation or a parent's
generation it's okay cool
time to settle down
what's up
you know my mom's always talking about
your roots yeah like what's the city
what's the school
what's the community environment you
want to go
like you stick the the steak in the sand
stays there first we're here forever
right
and uh so i think with that intention
because we grew up in that generation
that's
i mean like
frankly and honestly speaking stability
that really is what we're after yeah
right so even when we got our uh our
first foreign first forever home
which was out there in la in like east
l.a area
um we looked at everything schools
amenities drive to the gym drive to the
office we looked at the community looked
at the high school junior high and
elementary school
uh commuting distance from your mom's
house from my dad's house like we
considered so much distance from the
airport because we know we travel like
literally everything you know
and we're like okay this is it and we
built like a dream backyard like that
backyard is so awesome
it's big play play basketball
swimming pool friends come over we use
the hot tub you know oh i thought you
were talking about the first first photo
that one that one i knew it was not a
forever home true because that was what
did i do that was a starter we knew yeah
we knew that we're gonna outgrow it real
fast right
um so yeah so we did all that right and
then that was literally at
before the pandemic
during the pandemic the biggest thing
that sprouted from that is the entire
work remote uh movement
right from the point where like like we
have a buddy now who just got hired at
facebook
and he was he was like i'm gonna go live
in indonesia and i'm like what you can
do that you don't gotta like work in
silicon valley goes no majority of these
positions
are
work wherever you want as long as you're
in you're working in the same time zone
um it's completely cool and so i think
we literally are at the cusp of this
giant
shift in how many offices in our
building are vacant now yeah how many of
our friends are going on like
well i have a like my partner's in you
know this state this other person's in
this state our graphic designers in this
country yeah yeah like we are literally
at this giant paradigm shift in
uh the way businesses are ran yeah the
way people live like i know so many uh
uh businesses now that are in seven or
eight figure range like high seven to
low eight figure range and then i'm
picking their brains and i'm like so you
guys don't have an hq like nope and i'm
like where does this person live oh
michigan where does this person oh
philadelphia where's this person in
florida i'm like
what the i'm like so how long have you
guys been operating like that like past
eight years
i'm like what so now like the business
entity is just the agreement that this
is what we're all gonna do
but that they have no corporate office
or anything like that i've met so many
businesses like that yeah my graphic
designer is in malaysia or this guy's in
over there
and i think because of that as much
since we do have a kid as much as we do
want to have our roots and have that uh
community that community and achieve the
feeling of a forever home yeah
i don't even know if that's practical or
uh
if that's really gonna be the case even
though i think for us
that's something we
in our heart of hearts we want to chase
after yeah i just don't know if things
are set in stone not just for us but in
this generation
as it was before yeah i agree yeah
absolutely agree um but so far i really
do like nevada and vegas and the people
in it um and the people running it
um
so
yeah no real thoughts of like
leaving a forever home yeah like i i was
talking to a friend the other day about
um vegas
and i was like you know what i love the
most about vegas and they're like what
i'm like
i think it's the amsterdam
of the us
it's the place where the most things fly
i think that's florida dude no
i said i think it's the thing where the
most things fly
on all sides
which i think that's why i love it
because it's really a place where
it's your choice so for example um i
don't like to get political or anything
like that but just to kind of paint the
picture
i don't like to get political but i'm
about to get no i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say what my positions are but i'm
gonna say what the what the landscape
looks like nevada is a place
where you can defend the lgbt community
with a gun
those are on two opposite sides yeah
you know what i mean it's like that's
how cool it is that's why i love nevada
it's like literally you choose you like
what all america has to offer on both
sides i think everything is legal
here
right it's like oh you you you believe
in abortion cool you can have an
abortion here at the same time
you can also own
a gun
you know and it's just like it's it's
like going down both sides left and
right whatever the arguing points are
nevada's like yeah we'll do both here
it's like no questions asked oh you like
um you like a very good like well taken
care of infrastructure like really
smooth highways freeways we even saw
those like teenage crisis zones right
we're like oh if you're in trouble or
like you're about to be on the verge of
homeless come here like the safe haven
yeah like their safe haven like their
like welfare system is really good right
at the same time no state income tax
it's like what the [ __ ] because
california is is the whole reason why
they go like we have a we have a very
well supported welfare system because we
tax so hard yeah but nevada is literally
like you go down on both the list on
both sides and somehow i don't know how
they do it
everything is they're able to do on both
sides when you think when you when when
the way it's pitched in the media is
that they're on polar opposites yeah
yeah they can't coexist but it's like
everything caused extra and i think
that's what makes me
um like it so much yeah and so um
forever home
it's i don't know we're chasing after it
we don't know if that'll be it but so
far we really really like this state and
the city yeah
now a word from our sponsor at better
help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life like really think about that
because that's how our brains work so
why don't we treat them the same way how
we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so if your mind is in a
bad place and i've been there almost
everything that comes at you is taken in
with a negative light and also
opportunities that come become problems
you know but when you're in a positive
place you can have problems and you see
opportunity so that's why it's important
to invest time to take care and make
sure that your brain and your mind is
healthy and there's plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain now like
learning a new language or taking power
naps and there's also better help online
therapy and i think this is freaking
amazing because i truly believe we're in
an age
where technology has advanced past our
biology like back in the day you just
know a few of your neighbors you might
know some local news some big like
nationwide news but in this day and age
like the amount of stimulus you get is
bombarding like on on your instagram
feed you can already just have thousands
of stimulus you have bad news here bad
news there
um constant
overload sensory overload and that is
the new age that we're in right so i
think what we can do is we can't really
change that but we can do is help us
process that which is why i think it's
so awesome to have better help which is
online therapy because you make it
convenient you don't have to go in
person and take time out of your day so
just as quickly you can sign up for
appointments and um they offer video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions which is freaking cool so you
don't even have to see it on camera if
you don't want to
and it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
up with a therapist in under 48 hours so
that's really soon so if you need help
processing anything
boom betterhelp can help you right then
and there and it's always a good idea to
bounce some ideas off of someone
especially
if your ideas are negative and
especially if that person is a
professional so our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
get close that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash get close better help dot
com get close to get 10 off your first
month
next question
raymond cloud wants to know
fitness is important to you
but is there a point in your life where
fitness has failed you
i can go first too
uh yeah go first never
yeah same because i'm like
fitness never
it only makes you [ __ ]
look doper perform better
healthier
i don't yeah i don't know where it would
be so fitness
and uh i'll zoom out a little bit uh
raymond cloud
a ramen cloud
um
yeah wrong and cloud so i'll zoom out a
little bit more
the actual definition of fitness
is
uh
your
physical ability to adapt to the
endeavor at hand
that's
a person's fitness so
there is fitness to guitar playing do
your fingers have callous do you have
articulation
there's fitness to
rapping can you enunciate when you're
saying all these words over the rhythm
and talking them you know that's fitness
do you have enough mouth fitness to to
like
do something that buster rhymes can if
you don't then you're like
yeah then you're lacking yeah in the
mouth fitness area so that's what the
actual term of fitness is
uh when it comes to the fitness that
he's referring to i'm thinking he's
talking about jim jim right so in that
regard that is uh
how well your
body reacts to exercises or to the
external like sports or athletic
endeavors that you have
for me
that very definition is impossible
because the whole point of working on
your fitness is to be a better
vehicle
version vehicle of yourself to do
bigger and more fun things
so i think in that regard that's how i
approach fitness the fitness industry on
the other hand um if he's referring to
this i'm not or he or she is referring
to this but if they're like talking
about like insecurity or i'm trying to
get down to a specific weight and then
so i starve myself in an unhealthy way
like the fitness industry
is a completely different yeah it's a
completely different endeavor but that's
not how i feel witness i view fitness
based off the definition how well
adapted is your body to the endeavors
you want to put upon it and for me
that's why i'm always training for
something you know so if i'm like
um
if i'm gonna have a powerlifting meet
strength is number one if i have a
marathon to train for cardio is number
one when i'm doing my maintenance my
maintenance is to be the most well
adapted dad possible so i'll do like
lots of bear crawls lunges and stuff
because i'm like okay being a dad to me
is if tycoon wants to get on the ground
crawl through [ __ ] that's me i can't be
like oh
my back whatever you know so
fitness also to me is um
one of the few things that's so
objective where you literally
troubleshoot parts of yourself and you
go how do i make a better b better c
better you formulate a plan execute on a
b and c look at the results
did it really make a difference yes
rinse and repeat no take that out
the box jumps didn't really make me a
better dad or make me a better squatter
or whatever or i did and then you know
so that's why i love fitness and it has
drastically improved my life
even like even like the libido right
like the sex drive all of that we were
talking about all of that in an earlier
question and i think
um
well i don't think i should stop saying
that but
yeah fitness is nothing but positive
like it doesn't ever really take away
unless we're talking about like injuries
and stuff but that's all still very
preventable like and it's part of the
game
yeah
um like i actually really enjoy injuries
because um
like i don't look forward to them
but injuries it's one of those things
where like let's say you injure your
shoulder
now you are and you're exploring a
different mindset that you've never
explored before how do i rehab the
shoulder yeah and through injuring it i
learned way more about my shoulder
anatomically and then how do i
strengthen it through its range of
motion like i learned so much more as an
athlete when i actually injure something
yeah so if we could zoom out a hundred
percent then it's talking about failures
right like that is considered a failure
and then it's like how do you overcome
this adversity yeah exactly and that's
literally so adaptable in life yeah and
even with fitness it's very adaptable in
life because it's this discipline that
you have to have to continue to do
something even if you hate it especially
if you hate it you should be doing it
yeah or even if it like uh
medically they say you need to stop
but life doesn't stop
like how do you keep pushing forward
when you have adversity yeah yeah safely
right
um and and yeah like fitness
applies to so many aspects in your life
that's why i'm like when you when i
heard that question i'm just like i
have never seen it be bad for me like if
anything it's a giving thing you know
because remember like i i one of my
things was i [ __ ] hate running i
[ __ ] hate running i hate it right
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i think what life
teaches us is anything you hate is what
you have to do you have to do it you
have to do it and then so i was like
[ __ ] it this year i need to run four
miles comfortably without giving it a
second thought no hesitation complete it
and i was able to achieve that and now i
have this confidence of like yeah i can
run
you want me to do 10 miles vlog is going
to be hard but i know how to get there
and have this confidence that i'll be
able to achieve it you know um and it
and it also builds that the confidence
right because you're leaning into [ __ ]
that you hate it builds discipline it
builds routine it builds
so many things
i could keep going on and on and on
about all the benefits of fitness
and training and all that yeah so yeah
i've never seen a bad thing come from it
yeah me neither never ever failed me
okay
uh next question
from hellotron
hello pressure to have a second child
and thoughts
yes big pressure big big pressure what's
the big big pressure
my biological clock you know like i feel
like um the human race has evolved so
much and we've gotten so smart that
we've been able to build medication and
lifestyles and and look into science to
prolong our our life
but the biological clock the woman's you
know window of which of where she can
have a kid yeah we've probably we've
we've probably extended a little bit
but not without a lot of the risks that
are included in it right yeah so like my
biological clock although the you know
30 is an e20
is
it that's it's still the same thing as
it was in my mom's era and my grandma's
era and all that so i'm like [ __ ] i'm
right at the cusp of like yo [ __ ] you
getting old as [ __ ] to have kids like
i'm right at it like i'm staring at it
it's like right there it's in front of
my [ __ ] you're also very healthy and
you take good characters and but like
and i take good care of you too
[Laughter]
we we do we are we're very healthy
people but
like
you know your eggs are old like we're
born with our eggs they do smell bad
yeah our eggs are in our body from the
day we're born you know so like
they've just been chilling you know and
every time they cough now there's a
little dust coming out you know they're
not as like
vibe vivacious and vibrant and happy and
chipper as they were when i was like
[ __ ] 15 you know what i mean so like
that pressure is definitely there
because i feel like i haven't even
scratched the surface the surface on
things that i'm trying to achieve i feel
like i'm barely getting a grasp on who i
really am and i'm like really loving
like i loved myself before and i love
myself even more in a different way that
i'm like [ __ ] i'm not ready yeah the one
makes you want to have one why don't we
just call it
call it a day here so you can continue
exploring who you are and falling more
in love with yourself um
because that's gonna be a continuous
thing for me like i don't ever seem it's
kind of like a rela it is a relationship
right yourself yeah relationships
they should never just stop you should
never just be complacent in a
relationship and everything is is just a
straight line that's that's not a
relationship anymore that's just two
people coexisting yeah um
uh life is like ups and downs and turns
and [ __ ] sidewinds and [ __ ] and and
relationships are the same way and
relationship to yourself should be the
same you should constantly be trying to
evolve involve who you are and like how
you know you view yourself and who you
want to become and
um
and and like i was saying in an uh in a
i think i said this in a different
podcast but we're all products of the
people we meet you know so like you're
you should never be the same person um
so because of that i know it's going to
be a lifelong thing
that i am so looking forward to because
i love change
um
but to answer your question as to like
why don't i just stop is because you and
i we've had this discussion too where we
we live in the now but we also live in
the future 5 10 20 30 40 years from now
and we'd like to see what that looks
like right because whatever decision we
make in the present is definitely gonna
affect all that [ __ ] so like right now
i'm feeling this pressure and i'm going
i don't want to but what is that going
to look like at a you know at christmas
you know and it's it's we're in our 80s
and it's just taikan we're like
i don't like i love him and i don't want
to disrupt that relationship that i have
with tykan and like he's such a special
dude
that i'm like oh i don't want another
kid you're perfect you know but then now
imagine if he has a brother now and he
has someone he could lean on like
there's just so many things to consider
man yeah that that's where the pressure
comes from yeah cause it's like one is
very selfish
i guess both are very selfish right
because i don't have to have another kid
yeah but now that i do i'm trying to be
selfless
for
taika assuming that he wants another kid
or a sibling um i guess it all comes
from a selfish place but i think
i think i know what's best
and and how i feel about it now will not
be how i feel about it later 10 20 30 40
years ago i mean from now yeah for me i
think my only pressure is just you where
uh
if it happens i think it happens it was
meant to be it's in the carts
but if it doesn't happen then it's like
tech is really cool you know and i like
what we're doing now because i don't
feel so i put this pressure on myself
that i just talked about but i don't
feel pressure from you and i really do
appreciate that even though i know
you are on my side going whatever you
want ultimately you know what i want
which i know you want another kid yeah
but if it doesn't happen you're not
going to be heartbroken so i understand
our first model is really cool yeah he's
pretty bad we had like a [ __ ]
whack-ass first one i'm like dude we
need a second we didn't make up for i
don't think we would ever have any
whack-ass kids you know what i mean
we're not whack-ass people oh fine
whack-ass people have black ass kids so
don't be a whack-ass person and you'll
have a [ __ ] rat-ass kid yeah tycho is
[ __ ] cool i'm his number one fan
he's [ __ ] rad
i don't yeah if you're rad you're gonna
have rad kids like i don't ever see
not rad people not have rat kids
um so if you have white kids because
you're [ __ ] whack
um
what was i gonna say
i mean you said it oh that yeah that
like
the
that uh the pressure is more so i lost
it i was just talking about how [ __ ]
whack people can be and they blame their
kids for being whack nah oh you wack
here's another one
haul of juice wants to know how do you
deal with toxic family members
this is a really tough one so um
i think i have
two main toxic family members that don't
even know they're toxic
and it's my mom my dad
and it's not even their fault i don't
even think they're toxic
they're not toxic i think toxic is like
really dysfunctional
and like um like a toxin right like it's
it's i don't think toxic people know
they're toxic though
but i don't think your parents are toxic
you don't think so no i just think
they're hard to deal with but i don't
think they're toxic because they're not
trying to um
unintentionally sabotage anything no one
is
i don't know toxic people
unintentionally
are like they're just they come in and
you're just like [ __ ] man there's gonna
be drama everywhere i know but they're
not trying to they don't even know that
all right fine that's fair you know what
i'm saying that's fair i got it yeah i
think it's there's toxic and then
there's bad intentions true right i
think toxic people they're the ones that
are like oh my god everybody go there's
so much drama
but they don't know they're the ones
causing the drama you know what's
something funny that i've been noticing
what and
uh never mind go continue and then i'll
tell you later okay so yeah podcast tell
you later in the vlog so my my mom and
my dad to me
um because i also think toxic is
subjective fine i'm going to tell you it
seems like you really want to know okay
go ahead
so you know that that really popular eye
thing is coming back like what like the
evil eye like you put this eye thing
like a pendant or something or earrings
like you wear this eye and it's supposed
to reflect
deflect any negativity or toxic okay so
fine that's a boom it's a piece of
jewelry now that it's i mean it's an old
thing okay but it just made its way back
in okay right and like people mainly
girls will wear this like like if they
have like an eye to do
to like get rid of like bad bo vibes or
like evil intentions or whatever like
that's what it's supposed to do ward off
all these bad things right okay but i've
noticed
that the people that are always wearing
it are usually the [ __ ] toxic people
oh so like i've seen this pattern of
people that wear it religiously and i'm
like
[ __ ] you need to face that [ __ ] at
yourself so my mom's one of them then
does she wear it
i mean she has her versions of it her
buddhist versions of it
yeah i've just you know like everything
it's been a coincidence every sharp
corner of the house or some sort of
mirror to reflect bad vibes or you know
it's just the buddhist version or her
feng shui version of it yeah no but i
guess i've just specifically seen it
with the eye oh yeah i'm talking i'm
zooming out more than that i'm like that
represents this and my mom has that in
her own way oh my mom has her mirror
thing too but she's not a toxic person
same [ __ ] then
all right whatever what i mean it's just
everyone has just stopped asking me for
the cheesemas then everyone has their
own bug repellent in their own way true
right but then they're not realizing
that they're the ones attracting the
bugs
that's why am i attracting bugs it could
be i don't know that's so true yeah so
yeah so my mom and my dad and also i'm
saying that toxic to me is subjective it
is because it could be cultural
right like the asian tiger parent um it
just doesn't work here because over here
it's all about pursuing your own
passions like fulfilling your own
identity appears to be toxic yeah over
there
it's stellar that's what's good
parenting it's normal yeah like
everyone's doing this so it works in
that world you're not a lazy person then
if you take the american passion
pursuing culture you throw it over there
and you're going against the grain
you're a toxic person yeah wait you
wanna for your own
personal
uh gain you wanna disrupt the collective
yeah and that's my answer
what that understanding where people are
coming from yeah so for me toxic is also
subjective right like it's not toxic is
only for this specific circumstance so
for me because i'm i grew up american
my parents uh ways are toxic to me it
might have worked in the past but they
have to adapt if they want to be in this
new culture
a new type of
interaction and environment
so for me
how i've learned to deal with them over
the years is to set boundaries not in a
confrontational way
but to always state
what is happening
how it affects me and what the
consequences are and also not in a
vengeful way and not emotional not
emotional too like uh not backlash not
state because sometimes you're emotional
you're in you're in you're just like
aggressive you're just saying [ __ ] you
don't even know you're saying in a bad
way yeah
and what's been amazing is um i've seen
a lot of change in my pops you know just
by me like having sit downs and like
trying to explain to him like oh man
when you say things like this it affects
me like this but this is where my true
intentions are so almost trying to like
if i pull the curtain aside and people
can see another perspective behind it
it helps them go
oh cause people don't know what they
don't know so they're always just gonna
always see it from their own point of
view but when i've been able to share
other perspectives um that's how i know
my dad's not like toxic on purpose
because he's not holding on to his
egotistical beliefs he's like
oh that's what i thought but now i see
something else i get where you're coming
from yeah i think that's the only way
you can co-exist
with family members is if they're
willing to see that yeah because if
they're not willing to see that then
they're truly toxic then they're truly
toxic yeah and that's not your
responsibility yeah if they think their
way is the way
even upon new evidence i think that's
when it's toxic because now it's no
longer no now it's no longer them trying
to make the relationship work with you
now it's just i need you to see things
my way yeah and if you're not down to
see that and if you're not comfortable
with seeing that
um
then it's not your responsibility to
change that
and that's hard right because a lot of
us grow up going hey blood's thicker
than water yeah you know like no matter
what you guys have to have each other's
backs and this and then you should like
show up at everything and this and that
and there's like a lot of [ __ ] drama
because of that and yes
blood is thicker than water um and at
the end of the day like even with my
toxic family members i'm going hey if
they're really in an emergency state of
course because because they're my family
i have that loyalty and that
responsibility to them to support them
no matter what so if they're in a
situation where they have no one else
and it's an emergency i have your back
but beside like on a day-to-day [ __ ]
we're just not gonna see eye to eye and
i'm okay with that um but if you're
trying to be negative and and bring and
like have me bend and twist in your
[ __ ] world
it's not happening like that yeah yeah
because there that means there's no
respect because i respect you enough to
see [ __ ] your way and re and and like
abide by that
and go okay fine i'll hold your [ __ ] up
to you but i i want the same thing
yeah so i same thing that you just said
there's boundaries yeah
and also sorry
and also i think it's really important
to have a non-emotional open vulnerable
conversation
because if you're like if you think
you're having a conversation but you're
yelling and you're heated and this it's
like nah you're not even ready to have a
conversation either yeah because you're
speaking from your own past hurt rather
than speaking from a place like yeah
from a place of let's arrive at a new
solution together yeah no if you're if
if you're getting
um rolled up then you're not making any
progress either yeah
cool
uh channy
dot lift wants to know
what are some of your most valuable
advice
to young parents
most valuable advice
so much can i tell you what i think my
one of the biggest things i learned this
of course
i realized that
there is no
right
dot
but everything is on a spectrum
of a bar
and you need to find the balance
of that bar
per kid
but looking for the greater good
so for example
i just actually had this epiphany
yesterday
cool i haven't heard it yet um
and it's uh
when
like you know for taika
we let him choose whatever clothes he
wants to wear
right in the morning from the [ __ ] that
i buy him which is all [ __ ] swaggy as
[ __ ] yeah um
but the main thing is choice
yes right he has choice
so
that extrapolated
can become selfish
can become
entitled
can become everything serves me
right
on that same bar
you go
to the other side the way i grew up
no choice
no freedom
the you extrapolate that
it can become
zero critical thinking
zero uh
zero
confidence
um but the pros is
extreme obedience
extreme conformity
and never uh going against a grain or
causing a disruption you're saying those
words and i'm so suffocated already i'm
going
obedience so not going disagree so my
epiphany
my epiphany is
there is no such thing as one virtue or
characteristic
purely in its state everything is a
sliding spectrum
and so because of that you have to
consider that um every pro has a con
every con has a pro
so all you're trying to do
is help
find that balance for the kid to produce
someone that's not entitled but also
zero confidence
and then
through your own narrative
and helping them create their own
narrative they understand where that
uh
thing goes so for example
in the morning
um
we let him have choice pick whatever you
want to wear right and he gets creative
he gets to exercise that but then in
other circumstances when you're in a
rush taika you're worrying this that's
it and a few questions why how come i
can't choose because we have to go here
because grandma is waiting for us so now
like he's understanding the the
because i think as a kid they're they're
kind of like spot learning circumstances
right and over the years they start
tying those two together so now that
he's going oh when i have the time i can
be as free as i want but when i have
other people waiting on me that's more
important i just got to get the job done
so that's the biggest epiphany that i
learned where i think people like a lot
of the questions like is it this or is
it this is it this or is it this and
it's both for all answers it's all both
because as hard working as you can push
someone as burnt out as they can be you
know it's always this so it's kind of
like learning like it's it's not just
all gas all breaks it's you got to learn
what the the balance of those are for
every single virtue that you're trying
to instill in your kid it's the biggest
epiphany
um
that i learned because every time i'm
talking to taika
like literally the second after i'm
immediately reevaluating the way i spoke
to him and trying to really understand
how he took that information
because
what i say out of my mouth
isn't that important how he receives it
and how he turns makes that his own
is the most important yeah so i'm always
trying to reevaluate the way that i say
things to go
did i say it in a way where he maximized
the receivable yeah yeah
oh
that's really good that's a really good
one um
so for me i'll zoom out zoom in crazy
and then i'm gonna like zoom in in the
middle so i'm gonna do a big zoom out
okay so for a parent
we're always thinking about how can we
be the best parents for our kids right
how can we teach our kids
obedience but freedom uh how to be smart
but have fun like there's that balance
that you're talking about
but we always neglect the biggest
contributor contributing factor to how
that will happen and that's ourselves
yeah um we're reading all these books on
how to be a parent but we're never
reading books on how to like fix our own
[ __ ] yeah we're never really like a lot
of we read books on
how to parent yes but not how to be a
parent yes and the being like your
walking role model yes is the biggest
parenting yeah so it doesn't matter how
you speak to them it does i mean
obviously there is
there it does matter right yeah like but
the
to a certain extent but the bigger um
the the the bigger impact is how they
view you living life how they view you
talking to people how they view you
carrying yourself um how they like they
are taking that in way more than
anything else like all the stuff that
like i see taika do that i'm like hey
don't do that when he's giving me
attitude immediately i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's me so instead of like obviously i
have to correct the behavior right
because i need to teach him that it's
that it's wrong and and then i have to
teach him what the correct
my perceived correct behavior is but
then i'm also like scolding myself going
like you can't you can't go hard on
taika because obviously he learned it
from you yeah right like like that one
[ __ ] trope when the kid's smoking
weed and the dad catches them and then
it's like i learned it from you
yeah yeah so
that's like the biggest one zooming all
the way out so the way you treat
yourself the way you treat your spouse
the way you treat your friends or like
their mom or whatever or they're yeah um
that's one thing you really have to
focus on so before even becoming a
parent already start thinking as a
parent
you know um now zooming way the [ __ ] in
something that really helps me with
building taika up and like supporting
him and and
literally just building him up is
allowing him to trust me
because that's the only way he's gonna
be able to that's the only way i'm gonna
be able to effectively teach him
anything
right like i have to teach him by
example but then i also have to like
he needs to to know that i'm not gonna
do him dirty you know
like
a small example would be like when he
was learning how to swim and i wanted
him to hold his breath and go underwater
that's such a daunting thing for a child
yeah right because he's thinking i
already can't swim i'm just gonna drown
i'm gonna die yeah well he doesn't even
know the concept of death but he just
knows that i'm gonna be really
uncomfortable he doesn't like it yeah
yeah i don't wanna do it it's scaly it's
very scary right yeah so then like
through trust my taika when have i ever
like one gone against my word right
because that's how you build trust if i
say i'm going to do something i have to
do something and i have to stick to it
um
when have i ever like hurt you
intentionally if if anything if any
discipline does have happen then it's
always explained like if you went a
timeout and it broke your [ __ ] heart
and emotionally you're feeling so bad
i'm like hey this is like after the
offense has happened you got to pay the
punishment after the punishment is done
we talk about it and now we we learn
from it so like i do all of these things
so that i can gain a lot of trust from
him so that i i can have him do
what i feel is best for him yeah um
and then
um i was gonna do a middle zoom and i
got so caught up i got so passionate
about what i was talking about
what's the middle zoom
[ __ ]
is it still trust based or no um
that's a super
super in super up i lost it um but yeah
i think looking at yourself first
and like working on all the [ __ ] that
you don't like about yourself trying to
heal all whatever trauma you have really
trying to work on that because that will
come out because having a kid is very
stressful it's very very very real is
the middle zoom something to do with
being present
i lost it oh okay um i moved on to a new
thought now
but yeah um
oh super oh i guess that was a i guess
that was that i guess that was the
middle one a super
micro one then a super zoomed in one
um would be yes being present
would just be like um
just just be with them like don't be on
your phone they they feel that a lot
they feel it like crazy um
the first time taika because i like
we're always working on our phone right
but the first time taika was like
he couldn't even speak yet and he was
already covering the screen because he
knew that there was this competition
happening and i was like wow
i'm a horrible parent you know so like
being very present they do feel that
yeah and all they want and you you
posted this on instagram i think it was
like this boy who was wiping his tears
yeah
i could already cry i just want you to
be there yeah and i'm like they just
want you there that's it oh i could cry
it's so cuny yeah like yesterday we're
uh playing with legos
and then um like he was like really
antsy
it's a little crackhead sometimes are
you gonna build it together or you wanna
like build two things separate put it
together you want to do it like what do
you want to do
i just want to be over here
and then on the okay so i just sat next
to him and i was just building legos on
my own and he just like
just calmed down
and we're just building we're just
having a really good time and i think
all he wanted me was just next to him
that's it they don't care about toys
they don't care about clothes they don't
care like about the disneylands like
it's fun for us i think that is
fulfilling for us because we're like oh
we're able to provide and we're able to
give them what we didn't have yeah but
they just want you
it's like the cuny and it's like the the
homeless guy with the dog
you know like the dog but people think
oh the dog wants the organic food i know
we always feel so bad for the dog
what they want this dog my dog only eats
whole chickens or like it needs to have
like this whatever like crazy
tempur-pedic mattress or whatever and
then but some of the happiest dogs are
with homeless dudes because they're just
with them they're just chilling the
whole time they're like yeah they're
sharing fleas
like parenting is really easy
right
but it's easy it's one of the easiest
things and one of the hardest things
because it's like you really have to
fight yourself
from all of your own [ __ ] and it's just
like be there for them that's all they
want you just want love yeah
i think uh we have one more right
yep we got room for one more
god why did i get so emotional
i think i just like take it so much you
do love them so much i got a couple of
questions let me see which one's a good
one
uh let's end with this one okay fuentes
chris's response is
who made
the first move we all know this
me all right well moving on next
question
next question because i'm irresistible
uh big wayne 91 wants to know
is times 100 entrepreneur mentoring or
life in general
big way 91 times 100 is life in general
and i think
the way that i created the class so uh
for those of you guys who have been
following the times 100 thank you so
much it's a mentorship group that i
created and i didn't want it just to be
kind of like a free-flowing one although
there is kind of like that q a section
at the end of every single one of my
classes
uh i wanted to
really get on paper the way that i
approached life because i think that's
the most important the way you approach
life is the way you're gonna approach
fitness is the way you're gonna approach
business career being a student
being a romantic partner and everything
so for me i like to start
big and wide and what's the framework
for that and then you can utilize those
skills and specialize in each specific
way
so times 100 i have a whole curriculum i
wrote out took me like six months to get
really all my thoughts down on paper
and it's a
eight week course and uh
by the time this podcast comes out i
think it's the last week actually
last week for class number one and uh
yeah we go through eight weeks of the
way that i like to structure and problem
solve and think about things and i i
developed it from my time in like the
military growing up in in a very
disgruntled
like
gangster type of childhood
with going to
college
fitness combining it with my over 10
years of entrepreneurship
combined all of that into this is the
framework that i think i've been living
myself and that has helped me uh gain a
lot of success in a bunch of different
endeavors in my life so that's what it's
about so there are people in my life i
mean in my mentorship class that
are already entrepreneurship and they're
taking that and adapting to whatever
they're doing there's also people that
are a student too taking that and
adapting it to school
so it's all regards if that's something
that you guys are interested in you can
go sign up um i won't have the next
class probably until august
um but you can sign up at times
100.com
just put your email in and we'll let you
guys know when
the next classes
yeah now you're a great you're a great
mentor and you're a great teacher and
you have like the best analogies because
there's sometimes like i love bouncing
excuse my ideas off of you because like
i'll be stuck and i think i'm a pretty
smart person
um and i like
do work out a lot of my [ __ ] um but
there are those times where i'm like
[ __ ] man i'm stuck on this thing and
then you'll say like the perfect analogy
and i'm like oh
that was perfect that's genius and i
hate complimenting you but i guess i
have to and i also i personally learn
the best from stories
like i hear someone else's story and i'm
like oh wow and that helps it apply to
my story
so in the times 100 group
because it's such a direct life live
interaction where people ask a question
or whatever or they tell me their life
circumstance
i it helps me rack my brain of the 10
years because i have so many stories
that i haven't even shared
um you know on youtube or podcasts and
stuff because i need that inspiration i
need that trigger so i'll hear it and
i'm like dude i totally understand where
you're coming from because of this and
i'll explain what happened
and uh it seems like a lot of people are
taking a good benefit from it too i love
it no everyone that's around you is
always inspired by you because of your
storytelling and
like your um
your ability to just
charge forward in anything that you're
trying to do like when you set your mind
to something you just [ __ ] break down
everything that is perceived to be
blocking you and you're like i'm gonna
[ __ ] succeed like a [ __ ] and
it's very rare so it's really dope that
you're like sharing these gems with
other people thank you you're welcome
all right well on that note these are
some really cool questions um i do like
these and i do want to continue to do
these um so
yeah i guess just stay close to our
instagrams because we do we will ask you
guys like hey ask us some questions
we're gonna answer on the podcast so um
it's gonna be geo underscore antoinette
and bart quan
um but besides that thank you guys so
much for listening like always
appreciate you love you very much and i
hope that you're having a wonderful day
uh and if you're not hopefully this
podcast made you feel some type of way
uh on the inside that you're like you
know what life is [ __ ] good right now
it's a rainy day but hey sun rainbows
always come after a storm so
keep your head up and we'll see you next
week
bye